on Friday and fought local armed groups
okay let's go back to the conflict in
Ukraine South Africa is President Cyril
ramaphosa says a group of African
countries will send a peace mission to
Ukraine and Russia as soon as possible
he said the countries include Senegal
Uganda and Egypt as well as South Africa
is a geopolitan politics and security
analyst he's joining us from Ankara
thank you very much indeed for being
with us how much are these African
nations in a position to act as
mediators for peace given their rather
turbulent history that many have seen
yes of course you know African countries
have been very concerned about the war
in Ukraine last year we did see uh
president Marcus all of Senegal who was
then the Au chairman and uh musafaki
Muhammad who Muhammad who is the chair
of the commission visit President Putin
to discuss the situation in regards to
Ukraine and also of course president
zelinski had a video call with the Au as
well so since the war broke out African
countries have been very concerned even
though the continent has been split the
Au in particular has been very active in
trying in trying to push for a political
solution so countries like South Africa
for instance they are positioned right
from the get-go has always been that the
resolution that we've seen at the unga
have not reflected enough commitment to
a dialogue and peace process that is why
they've abstained from all of the UNG
resolutions it's about six of them that
we've had so far so I think this new
initiative may also be more from South
Africa's part me also motivated by
recent reports that South Africa
supplied weapons to Russia you know that
is a very serious issue it would then
move South Africa from its official
position of active non-alignment to
being obviously aligned with Russia so
this would serve as a very good way to
sort of change the narrative change the
conversation that is that is a engulfing
South Africa at the moment in regards to
Russia and the Ukraine war many of the
countries of course in the African
continent have been badly hit by the
flow of grain supplies that have been
coming not only from Ukraine but also
from Russia as well including also
fertilizer supplies from Russia
restrictions and those two how much of
this is about trying to find a peaceful
solution and how much of it is about
protecting African nations interests
well I think the war has been
devastating for countries all over the
world African countries included we know
of course the situation in Somalia was
was was very critical at the point and
when we got the green Supply to Somalia
it was such a relief for Somalia and all
the other countries the whole of Africa
that have had issues uh with regards to
food security however I think it it's
also been played at a blown out of out
of proportion in terms that not many
countries are really dependent on Russia
and Ukraine's supplies but the cutoff of
Russian request supplies increased
Global prices and it is the price that
has really been you know the issue so
with the African continent yes there's
vulnerability to the uh to supplies or
supply shortages from Ukraine to the
Black Sea and from Russia and that of
course is one of the motivate one of the
motivation why African countries won
this won the war to end however I think
the broader fear is that we are in where
the cops were even not in the middle of
of good power competition that is
leading in very closely to war and all
that war will be very devastating for
African countries because their own
resilience you know it's not it's not as
strong as other countries in other parts
of the world so I think if we consider
these factors we can see where African
countries want to be very much actively
engaged in the political process
we appreciate it so thank you very much
indeed for your time
tell him I had on the NewsHour including